新しいベイブレードを買ってから約3週間が経った
あのハマりすぎちゃって
気付いたら、こんなに沢山買っちゃいました
楽しいんすよ
今のベイブレード超楽しいんすよ
なんなんだろうね
やっぱ壊れるっていうのがね
デカいんすよ
やべぇ楽しい
やっぱりね壊れるっていいよ
壊すって楽しい
というわけでベイブレードにドハマりしてるんですけど　も！
僕、ベイブレードする時いつもこのスタジアムでやってるんですけども
まあこのスタジアムもですね
僕も何千回と回してきたんで
中々傷付いてきて結構ボロボロなんです
というわけで今日はたまにはね、違う場所でベイブレードやってみたいと僕は思ったわけなんで
今回新しいステージを準備しました
こ　ち　ら　！
今日は
段ボールをハサミと手を使うことなく
開けてみたよ
こんな無駄な作業・・・
おっしｷﾀ――(ﾟ∀ﾟ)――!!
待ってましたー
今回買ったのはこちら
いやもう中華鍋と言うのもふさわしくない
僕はもうこれ調理器具として買ったわけではないですから
鉄製のスタジアムと思って僕は買いましたから
うわすごい
wwwwww
すげーよ
完全にスタジアムっすよ
なんかねアニメのベイブレードだとね
こういう場所でベイブレードするんです
アイツら多分中華鍋でやってんじゃねぇか
いや～これはすごいよ
普通のスタジアムと比べると大きさはかなり違いますね
ただ結構深いからさ
なんかねぶっ飛んだりすることはない気がします
回したい
では早速回してみましょう
じゃあまずは僕が愛しているヴァルキリーで回してみましょう
攻撃タイプだとグルグル回るんでどう動くかがポイントですね
なんだと！？
ヴァルキリーが通用しない
あ、なんとか着地はできたぞ
あんまり大振りに回転しすぎると
深すぎて側面が当たって止まっちゃいます
うるさい
次はディフェンスタイプでやってみます
ディフェンスタイプは真ん中に止まるんで多分大丈夫だと思います
いいんじゃない？
ディフェンスタイプはちゃんとできるね
さてと戦ってみますか
最近僕の中で一番強いディフェンスタイプのやつと
持久力のあるドライバーなんですけど
攻撃タイプのレイヤー
エクスカリバーですね
ちょっとコイツらで戦わせてみましょう
大回りになるタイプじゃないんで
やべーぶっ飛んでっちゃった
うるさいー
あああああああああああああああああ
結果
中華鍋でベイブレードをするとうるさい